[Music]
welcome back
so today we're continuing this lecture
series on reinforcement learning which
is one of my favorite topics at the
intersection of control theory and
machine learning and actually also at
the intersection of biological learning
so really really old rich topic
decades of development and especially
recently there's a lot of renewed
interest in reinforcement learning
because of
its combination with deep neural
networks
and so today i'm going to focus
primarily on model-free reinforcement
learning
and specifically on gradient-free
methods
so this lecture is going to culminate in
q-learning which is one of the most
popular reinforcement learning
techniques
available today
so that's this q learning here which is
an off policy gradient free method
and to build up to q-learning we're
going to have to introduce some concepts
like monte carlo learning
and temporal difference learning
and td learning especially temporal
difference learning has really deep
connections to biological learning how
we actually learn
in our kind of coupled network of
neurons
so i'm really excited i think this is
going to be a pretty neat lecture
and just a reminder this is roughly
following a new chapter in the second
edition of our book uh data driven
science and engineering so this is a
chapter i put together kind of to be the
the end cap of the control section
because reinforcement learning really is
such a an exciting uh kind of a
growing set of techniques
okay good so model free reinforcement
learning specifically gradient-free
methods today
now before uh jumping into kind of all
of the the gradient-free optimizations
i'm going to talk about which is going
to culminate in q-learning i want to
introduce or kind of recap a couple of
topics that we talked about in the last
few video lectures
so the first thing that is really
important is just to remind you
that there exists this quality function
q
which essentially tells you the joint
quality or value
of taking an action a given a current
state s
so the value function v tells you what
the value of being in a current state s
is assuming you take the best action
this quality function is somehow richer
and it contains more information about
what is the quality of being in this
state
s for any action i might take so this is
the joint
quality function is kind of sometimes
what we call it
and this quality function can be defined
using kind of the standard
markov decision process mdp language
that we've also introduced
where it is the expected future reward
uh given that i am in a state s now and
i take an action a
so it is the expected reward function uh
currently the the instantaneous reward
i'm going to get taking action a now
which will lead me to state s prime
plus any future rewards that i might get
uh just for being in that next state s
prime okay so we we talked a lot about
this in the last lecture
and this is essentially just saying that
the uh
the quality of being in a state now
is my expected current reward plus all
of my future rewards for being in the
next state that i'm gonna jump to and
you can write it out in terms of this
summation over probabilities because
this markov decision process this mdp
which is kind of the cornerstone of
a lot of reinforcement learning
algorithms
assumes that your environment the the
environment that you find yourself in
evolves probabilistically so there's
kind of a coin flip uh randomness
element to how the state evolves even
given uh the same action so even if i
take the same action in the same state i
might have different
future states according to some
probability and that's given by this
function p
so s prime again is my future state
s is my current state and a is my
current action
and so this expected value here has to
be summed up over all of the possible
future states s prime i might find
myself in which are given by this model
this this probabilistic evolution p
so right off the bat what i want to
point out and this is why uh we need
this lecture that i'm going to give you
today
is that all of the learning that we we
have demonstrated kind of using the
bellman equation and dynamic programming
up until now so policy iteration and
value iteration
assume that you have a model for this p
this probabilistic markov decision
process that evolves your your system
forward in time and we also assume that
we have a model for this reward function
and you can then optimize
using this knowledge
and if you have this quality function
remember that you can derive the value
function at a state s it's simply the
best possible action you could take it's
the quality
for the best action a you could take
and similarly you can derive the optimal
policy pi
it's simply the a that maximizes the
quality function it's the action a that
maximizes the quality function
but again the central challenge what we
talked about in the past lecture
was dynamic programming uh using bellman
optimality when we actually have a model
for p and for r when we have a model for
how the system evolves and what the
reward is as a function of the state in
action
but in many systems we don't actually
know how the system is going to evolve
we don't have a model for that and we
don't know what the reward function is
or what the reward structure is before
kind of exploring and trying things out
so that's going to be the motivation for
these
kind of
model free reinforcement learning
algorithms i'm going to talk about today
so this is just recap i wanted you to
remember the quality function is really
important we also have a value function
and a policy pi
and again you know if i had a model for
p and i had a model for r i could run
through this value iteration where i
would essentially take actions that
maximize my value and i would update my
value function
uh at every state that i evolve on on
some trajectory so let's say i'm playing
chess i would just play chess over and
over and over again and every state i
find myself in i would use my best
policy to get my best action a
and i would somehow update the value of
my
current state s
using the new reward information
that i get
so this all relies on on bellman's
equation
but we're going to talk about today when
we don't actually have access to a model
so when we don't have access to a model
for how the system evolves or what the
reward structure is we essentially are
stuck using trial and error learning
and that makes a lot of sense in a lot
of biological situations too right the
first time that you play tic-tac-toe
maybe the person that taught you told
you you know that three x's in a row
wins or three o's in a row wins but they
didn't tell you what the value
of a particular state was and they
didn't give you a model or a rule for
how this game is going to unfold you
just had to play a bunch of games learn
the rules and learn the reward structure
okay
and so the simplest approach and i don't
actually really recommend doing monte
carlo learning unless you have to but
this is almost to illustrate the
simplest approach
uh to model free learning learning
purely from trial and error is called
monte carlo learning
and so in monte carlo learning what
we're going to first do
is define this this cumulative reward
function
so monte carlo learning is what's called
an episodic learning algorithm which
means that it needs to run an entire
episode
many many states
action sequence leading to some final
end of the game
before it can it can use that
information for learning
and so monte carlo learning works you
know in theory for things like games
that have a definitive end or maybe if
you're trying to make a a racer you know
a bipedal walker race to a finish line
that would have a definitive end
for that that episode as well
and so what you do is you essentially
you pick some policy and you enact that
policy and you run through your game you
play your game of chess or you run your
race
and you compute your cumulative total
rewards of course discounted by this
gamma we always discount by gamma
because that's how we can prove
optimality in certain conditions
and so based on this total cumulative
reward
the simplest thing we could possibly do
is take
and divvy up that reward equally among
every state
that uh
that my system took on the way to the
finish line
okay so that i'm going to demonstrate
this for for value function learning and
it can also be done for q learning
and so essentially what we would do is
at the end of an episode once we've
computed this cumulative reward how much
did i gain over that episode
i would say that my my new value
function at every single state
along the way
is equal to my old value function
plus i essentially take and i add a
little bit of this r sigma divided by
how many steps there were in my uh in my
trajectory
to my my value function so this is
essentially an update that says that
we're our best estimate for our value
function is still kind of the old value
function
but any states that we
we hit along the way to the finish line
we are going to add the cumulative
reward divided by the total number of
steps
now this is a very inefficient way of
learning you have to play tons and tons
and tons of games of chess or
tic-tac-toe
uh to actually
learn this way because what you're
assuming is that every single step you
took along the way to victory is equally
important
to victory or loss is equally important
so for example if i played a brilliant
game of chess and then i made a bad move
at the end
all of those moves would be considered
equal in this scheme or if i played a
bad game of chess at the first game and
then my opponent got unlucky and lost
then i would actually wait all of those
bad moves
towards towards this updated value
function
but again this is the simplest kind of
most
common sense thing you could do to start
accumulating that information you've
experienced so this is the experienced
reward
and you just divvy it up over every
single step you took to get that reward
okay that's uh that's what monte carlo
learning is
and you can uh do the same thing for q
learning so you can also update your
quality function in exactly the same way
where basically uh every state action
pair that you uh
you saw along along the the trajectory
that you just played
would get updated again by um
a small amount
uh given by this reward divided by n
okay and you can kind of convince
yourself that this should be you know
an optimizer this should actually
converge under certain conditions okay
um and we're only updating based on the
difference between the reward and the
old value function or the reward and the
old q function
because if my old value function or q
function were perfect then they would
perfectly predict what this future
reward would be so if i had a perfect
value function this would actually be
this difference would be zero here and
zero here
so uh that's why we're kind of updating
with the difference between the actual
reward and the estimated reward
because that's kind of what this is this
uh v old and this q old here are
essentially my estimated future reward
being in state sk
okay good that's monte carlo learning
relatively inefficient
but one of the nice things about it is
that it has no bias okay so it's very
very sample and efficient i don't
recommend doing this in practice
but it has it introduces no bias
into the learning procedure if you play
enough games
in principle this should this should
converge
and you should do a thought experiment
of whether or not we should be enacting
our optimal policy pi or a sub-optimal
policy
uh if i was doing this i would always be
up uh enacting my optimal policy pi
kind of based on my new
either q function or or value function
but i want you to think through what
would happen if you didn't enact an
optimal policy pi
okay good so that's monte carlo learning
and that's kind of one extreme
and on the other extreme is what we have
called temporal difference learning and
td learning is one of the most important
advances that has happened in
reinforcement learning this is decades
old
and it gives us a better strategy in
many cases for learning
that essentially
uh it highlights events that are more
recently uh giving me rewards so i have
some state action sequence and i have
some rewards i've gotten along the way
and to some extent i want to say that
maybe the events that happen more
recently are somehow related to the
rewards i'm getting
and so that kind of difference in time
is is also a property of biological
learning systems so if you think about
pavlov's dog right pavlov's dog was
conditioned
to expect a food reward at some point
after hearing this bell ring and so if
you ring the bell you know the dog
starts to salivate
and so there is a finite difference in
time between the action or the state the
environmental cue and the actual
expected reward
so in monte carlo learning
you're basically saying that the right
action could have happened at any point
in the past leading up to the reward now
what temporal difference learning does
is it says there is kind of an optimal
time in the past where i am most likely
to be correlated with a current reward
and that's a tunable parameter i'll tell
you about
okay so i'm going to start with
something called td0 there's a whole
family of temporal difference learning
algorithms we're going to start with the
kind of zeroth model here
and again we're going to start by
looking at this in a value function
formulation so remember that the value
function at state now so subscript k
means at time k
so the value function at my my state now
at time k
is given by my expected reward now rk
plus a discounted value function at the
next state i find myself at sk plus one
okay
and this is a bellman's optimality
condition essentially that this can be
written recursively so the value
function now can be recursively written
in terms of the value function at the
next state i find myself in
and so what temporal difference learning
does this is different than monte carlo
learning
is that it updates the value function at
my state sk
and again it similarly starts with my
old value function and there is a
correction term
and what that correction term does is
instead of averaging over all of the
trajectory like what monte carlo
learning does
in td learning we have this uh this
first term here called the td target
estimate
and this if you look this term here is
almost exactly
the expected value function
okay
so this term here is what i expect my
value to be given a state s k and i take
its difference with the old estimate of
my value function at sk
so this is my my old best estimate of
the value of being in the current state
now
and this is new information of what
actually happened so i i take an action
i get a reward rk and i find myself in a
new state sk plus one where i have an
estimate of the value function
so this right here is my expected
value be of being at point s k
so i want to say that again this is
really important and it's a little
confusing
because of the bellman optimality
condition here where the value of being
in a state at time now
is equal to my reward now plus a
discounted value at being in this state
the next time step into the future
i can essentially say that my my
estimate of my value function
should look like my current reward plus
gamma times my next value function at
the next state
but if i actually am playing a trial and
error game if i'm playing a game of
chess using my supposedly best policy pi
i can actually take that step to sk plus
one i can get a reward or lose a reward
whatever and i can compute what this
actual
cumulative
um
we call it r sigma the cumulative reward
is
and if there's a discrepancy between my
my actual r sigma and my estimated uh
value
then i will update my value function uh
with some weight alpha here okay
so this is in in some sense it has the
same flavor of the monte carlo learning
i start with my old value function and
i'm iterating to find a new value
function every time i take a step
i'm iterating this
but now i'm using this kind of
bellman nested uh
reward our sigma to to update
and so this is called the td target and
this is called the td error the temporal
difference error
and it's kind of interesting so there is
actually evidence
that
there are
analogs of this in neuroscience so when
you know cells kind of fire together
wire together that's
that's one of the principles of
neuroscience
and dopamine when dopamine is released
it can strengthen connections um between
the the cells that fired together right
before dopamine was released those cells
will strengthen uh their their
correlation of firing together
and so there is a lot of really
interesting theory and experiments that
kind of connect
uh these td error signals and the
release of dopamine in actual biological
systems
so it's believed that there are circuits
in your brain and in your nervous system
that are actually estimating this future
reward this r sigma
and when uh i guess that would be this
this here this would be the estimate of
your future reward and then when you
actually get a future reward and it's
different than what you estimated you uh
you fire uh to strengthen those
connections
okay so this is nice because it also
this at least td0 is only looking one
time step into the future so you get
your reward now and you get your uh your
estimated reward one time step in the
future
and so this is a somehow waiting events
right before a reward takes place
so this is kind of a one delta t delay
between an action and a reward and that
one delta t
delay things that are correlated with
one delta t will get strengthened in
this td0 framework
okay um good so i already told you about
the strong connections to biological
learning with dopamine
but it you could
expand this value function out and this
would be rk
plus gamma rk plus one plus gamma
squared maybe i'll write it out here
plus gamma squared of my value function
two steps into the future
and i can do this as many times as i
want so this is kind of a two-step
uh expansion of my of my value function
using again the bellman optimality these
are
both completely equivalent to each other
and i can replace this estimate for r
sigma with this longer expression that
has two events in the past that has two
action state sequences
and so if i do that now i have uh kind
of a richer
set of experiences of what my actual
cumulative reward is now taking two
steps into the future and i can use that
as my uh to generate my my temporal
difference error signal that i use to
update my my value function
and you can imagine doing this as many
times as you want
you could have an n step
cumulative reward and in the limit as n
goes to infinity or to the end of your
episode this will actually converge to
monte carlo learning which is kind of
neat so at the very limit of temporal
difference learning as n goes to
infinity or to the end of your sequence
this will converge in some sense to
monte carlo learning
but if i take you know n equals zero or
one or two
then i'm waiting only a few steps in the
past more heavily
to update my value function
good so that's the idea of temporal
difference learning
and
let's see i'm pretty sure the next thing
i'm going to tell you about is probably
well okay in a minute we're going to
show you
that
essentially
q learning
is just temporal difference learning on
the quality function q so i'll show you
that in a minute
there's one last variant called td
lambda and essentially what it does is
it says instead of just using
a one-step temporal difference td0 or a
two-step temporal difference td1 or an
n-step temporal difference
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
compute that target that r sigma for all
of those and i'm going to weight them in
a certain way
using this kind of
exponential weighting with some some
factor lambda that's between 0 and 1.
okay so essentially what i'm doing is
i'm waiting all of the td algorithms and
then i use that uh weighted error
reward signal to compute my td error
and this has some nice uh some nice
properties you can kind of tune this
lambda depending on the problem you're
working on to get nice convergence
properties to wait kind of recent stuff
more or older stuff more
but you're kind of waiting all of them
instead of just ignoring
past events
good so td lambda is pretty pretty
interesting i believe this was
introduced by sutton
um originally
okay so q learning this is kind of the
culmination of what i really wanted to
show you
is that q learning is essentially just
temporal difference learning
on the q function
so i'm going to write it out okay so q
q learning it's it's exactly the same
template as temporal difference learning
we are going to play games we're going
to you know do trial and error learning
by trying our optimal policy
and we have an estimate of what the
quality given being in a state s taking
action a is
but that's not a perfect estimate we're
still learning and so what we do is we
measure what the actual reward and
future q function is at the next step we
find ourselves in
and we use this as the td target
for td learning
so again this is the the td target
estimate this is essentially my observed
cumulative reward
and i use that to generate an error
signal which i feedback to update my cue
function so essentially what this means
is that if i got more reward than i
thought i would i should increase my q
function at that s and that a
okay so that's what that means if i if i
experienced more reward than what i
expected i should have a positive
increase in my quality function at that
sk and ak
and you'll notice here this is a very
subtle difference i'm going to say this
again very subtle difference
here we're maximizing over a
so what we're actually doing
is we we take some step we take some
action a to get our reward rk
but it doesn't have to be our optimal on
policy action ak it could be i could
actually do some random action to get
this rk
but then when i'm computing my quality
function here for what my value kind of
is in that next state sk plus 1
we're going to optimize over actions a
at least to compute this td target
now this is a little bit strange but
i'll tell you kind of what this means in
a minute okay
so
we call that auth policy
which means that i can actually take
sub-optimal actions a i don't have to
enact my optimal current policy pi
i can take sub-optimal actions a to get
this
to get this reward
but then i do need to maximize over a to
get my my best uh
q function in this step of the the td
target okay and this has a lot of
benefits which essentially i can learn
from experience i can replay old
experiences even when i know that those
were not using an optimal policy pie
because i've learned more since then
or i can watch a grand master play and
even if my quality function's not very
good because i'm an amateur i can watch
their actions and learn from their
actions so i'll talk a little bit more
about this but that essentially is what
we mean by off policy
is that you can still learn even if you
take sub-optimal actions a
and you'll notice that this is a td0
variant because this is only taking one
step forward and then using the
recursive queue formulation
good
there is another variant so q learning
is off
policy td learning of the q function
and there's something called sarsa which
is on policy td learning of the q
function very closely related only a
tiny tiny difference but it's an
important one and i'll tell you about it
so sarsa means state action reward state
action it basically means you start with
a state action you take you're in a
state and you take an action
you measure a reward and then you uh are
in another state and you take another
action okay sarsa
and so here you'll notice that this is
the exact same expression the same exact
temporal difference learning expression
td0
except here i am not doing a max over q
a max over a
in this part of the td
estimate
and so what that means is that i
actually have to be taking my best
possible policy actions
a
a k plus 1
and a k at every step or else this will
start to degrade
my estimate
because the quality function q is always
my estimate of the quality of being in
that next state taking that next action
assuming i do the best thing forever
after
okay
and so if i don't plug into here my best
possible
a
and into here if i didn't take my best
possible action ak to get this reward
then this will actually be a sub-optimal
estimate of my my quality function and
it will start to degrade
as i iterate through
very subtle difference and i'll put them
next to each other so you can see the
difference
but this is what's called on policy
because you have to enact the optimal
policy for this to work
for this to converge and not degrade
one of the cool things about sarsa is
that sarsa can actually work for any of
the td variants i showed it for td0 here
but you can do it for td1 td2 tdn and
you would basically just replace this td
target here with a more complex or rich
expression
taking more steps
and again if you think about this what
this means is that you have to take
actual steps you actually have to take
actions and get that trial and error
experience and then you look back and
you see okay well what were my sequence
of events and rewards and you can use
that to update your quality function
after gaining that experience
good
so so uh yeah good this is um
yeah and you can essentially just
replace this
td target for the cumulative reward with
any old td algorithm you like td0 td1
tdn or
the temporal difference lambda scheme i
showed you a minute ago
okay and so this is on policy tv
learning of the quality function q
so i want to show these kind of
simultaneously next to each other so
that we can compare and contrast because
they are almost
perfectly identical okay except again q
learning is what's called off policy
and we enable q learning to be off
policy
by replacing this one a k plus one here
with a max over a here
because again the quality function and
the value function are
always assuming you do whatever is
optimal in the future so they're always
assuming that after the next step you do
the best thing forever after so it's the
optimal kind of quality of being in that
state
and so if you didn't maximize over a
here
then if you took an off policy a a
sub-optimal action a this would actually
degrade your quality function over time
but because we are actually optimizing
over a in our quality function at the
next step
we can take sub-optimal actions a to
explore and to learn from off policy
experiences
and again this is a huge huge benefit so
this kind of off policy this this single
difference here that allows us to be off
policy
is one of the things that allows q
learning to learn
from a lot of different types of
experiences so you can watch someone
else play a chess game and still learn
in an off policy manner even if your
quality function is not as good as the
grand masters that you're learning from
you can accumulate information about how
they play and improve your quality
function
so you can learn from imitation and you
can also learn by replaying your past
experiences even if they were
sub-optimal so when you go to sleep at
night and you dream of playing tennis
even if you are replaying things that
were not done perfectly because you've
learned throughout the day
you can still use that experience to
still improve
your quality function
and so the q learning often is faster at
learning because you can explore more so
you get better optimal solutions and
faster convergence
and oftentimes you get lower variance uh
solutions in i'm sorry i think this is
higher variance i think this is a typo
you'll have to check the book chapter
because i'm pretty sure that's a typo
um
okay good so
and when you do q learning there are
lots of strategies for how you introduce
randomness into the policy that for what
action you take
so there's something called epsilon
greedy which basically means
that one minus epsilon
you know of the time so let's say
epsilon is is 0.05 then 95 of the time
you would do your optimal policy
and 5 of the time you would do something
random you would do a random action to
get more kind of exploratory actions to
explore your space more so that's an
epsilon greedy algorithm
and in these epsilon greedy algorithms
often you start with a big epsilon so
you start by only doing random stuff
and then eventually that epsilon cools
down to zero in a kind of annealing or
simulated annealing strategy so as you
get more experience as you learn better
you eventually get to go more on policy
as that epsilon decays to zero so that's
a really important one called epsilon
greedy but there's tons of different
ways of introducing randomness and
exploration uh into your your off policy
search strategies
okay good uh and in you know contrast
with sarsa so it has some benefits also
so the benefits of sarsa is that it is
often safer in training because it is
always going to do what you think is the
best thing to do it's not going to
randomly explore so if you're teaching a
teenager how to drive you probably want
to be doing something more like sarsa
than q learning because you don't want
to just every epsilon
you know flip a coin and decide on some
random action that might take you off
the road or have some safety
issue
so sarsa because it's on policy means
you're always doing what you think is
the best thing
even though it's more conservative so
this will
learn less quickly and probably less
optimally but safer
while it's learning
and similarly
sarsa because it's always on policy it
typically will maximize
it will have more cumulative rewards
during the learning process so if i if i
care about how much reward i get during
my learning process then sarsa will
actually give me more cumulative reward
because it's always on policy it's not
making these occasional kind of bad or
sub-optimal moves just to gain
experience
and so it's an interesting trade-off
right like this actually has a lot of
parallels with human life as you might
expect and in biological learning
sometimes you want to be more
conservative sometimes you want to
maximize your rewards throughout the
learning process sometimes you put a
premium on
being able to take chances and you know
introduce some randomness and learn from
experiences that are not what you think
are the optimal experience you know go
backpacking in europe right that's a
that's a q learning
type of type of action
okay good um so what i hope i've
convinced you of is that when you don't
have a model for your mdp for your
markup decision process
there are things that are inspired by
dynamic programming in bellman's
equation
you can think of these almost as
approximate dynamic programming
based on trajectories of real world
experiences i actually take actions in
the real world through trial and error
and i start to accumulate information
that can give me a better world view of
what the quality of a given state action
pair are
and there are off policy and on policy
variations of this that have different
strengths and weaknesses okay
good so that's what we talked about here
is kind of this gradient-free model-free
reinforcement learning
q-learning is used a lot
for deep reinforcement learning and so
i'll definitely talk about that in a
future lecture all right stay tuned
there's more to come thank you